[Music]
so metrics that matter the remit for
this talk was basically alright fine you
know you're in charge of no I should
introduce myself so my name is Ben and
if Google ever stops working it's my
fault
forgot that part we did the intro in the
last session I was still I was running
with that more concretely I created the
site reliability site reliability team
at Google and still run it I also run
all of networking for Google and all of
data centers for Google from design and
construction to operation so it's a you
know it's a low stress job regular hours
and it teaches you a thing or two about
scale and my backgrounds of software
engineering so this is sort of the first
operationally oriented gig ever done in
my entire career it's been an
interesting learning experience but I
have learned a few things about scale
and one of the things that I've seen is
sort of the pattern over and over again
of the same small number of metrics show
up time after time in operating and
measuring and assessing software
services that are running at a decent
size scale and so rather than sort of
having a generic talk about metrics and
why they're important above all that you
already know that right skip all that
let me tell you the three that I've seen
over and over again actually are really
important if you want to have a great
user experience at the end of the day
and you don't want to have your service
collapse under its own weight so been
doing this since 2003 back then we still
had a cloud product we didn't call it
cloud at the time we called it Borg but
it was all of the things that you're now
familiar with in the public cloud
offering right we had services they run
in containers you have these relatively
homogeneous and entirely fungible
compute platforms that you run it on and
jobs can move around and things can die
and blah blah blah blah blah and you
know it was a good way to run the search
and it would turned out to be a good run
a good way to run Gmail and we've kind
of run with it and now of course it's a
something that we're offering to
everyone and the term cloud has picked
up but we've been doing this for a while
and in particular when I went back and
looked at kind of the scale of what
Google's been doing we've
through seven orders of magnitude so
four and still growing so who knows in a
couple of years this presentation may
read differently but we have managed
over that time to evolve some best
practices about sort of how you run
things and also how you measure things
we're gonna skip the how you run things
for a separate topic this is just about
measuring and again I want to notice a
note this is not everything that's
important to measure these are the
things that I've found really are both
critical and often not actually measured
because they're not easy to measure but
in retrospect you know after the bad
user experience or after the outage or
whatever you sort of go back and say wow
if only we had this is the if only we
had lists so item number one measure
your actual user experience seemed
straightforward right I mean you've all
put your time and effort and sweat
equity into building this service and
you know you test it yourself if you're
pretty much like everybody out there
your development team uses your own
product otherwise they wouldn't be
working in your company but you're
testing it you know here or in your
development lab close to your servers on
a really great network with fairly
little competition and probably Wi-Fi
backup you know so newsflash most of the
world does not experience your product
the way you are experiencing your
product in fact you know statistically
speaking very little of your user base
experiences it that way so rule number
one that we've come up with is measure
the actual user experience right because
your users don't care how well it works
you know on your awesome brand new pixel
on your Wi-Fi in your home office with
your data center 20 milliseconds away
they care it works for them and if it
doesn't work well for them somebody else
will build a product that does right I
know the answer but hang on right but
it's hard
I apologize let me move this thing it's
hard to measure the actual user
experience it's much easier to measure
telemetry that's coming back to our
servers or to measure you know what we
see in our test lab apologize speaking
of measuring the actual user experience
my first time with a headset and I think
it's not entirely agreeing with me so
you know why do most teams not actually
measure what their users are
experiencing well because you know you
can't exactly talk your user base into
putting a GoPro behind their head every
time they're using your product so you
can see what's going on that's right now
that has a very low adoption rate and
it's not actually easy to measure
especially you know a mobile experience
or in particular a web-browser
experience back when everything was the
client you could kind of instrument your
thick client and you'd have a decent
sense of what the user experience was
like but when you have all sorts of
other layers of software in between your
app and what the user is doing and then
you also have a network and maybe you
have a browser etc it gets much harder
and so as a practical matter what I see
often is that teams approximate this
right they'll put in some decent
server-side monitoring they may even
have a test lab where they get some
benchmark results like how long does a
page take to load and so on but they
aren't actually measuring the
distribution of what the user experience
is because it's difficult my advice for
all of you yes it's hard get through
that denial and go down to actually
measuring a thing and if you have to
spend 10% of your engineering team to do
it do it right because that is what your
user experience is and you're spending
the other 90% trying to write a software
service or a feature or a cool widget
and you have no idea what people
actually see when they try to use it
right so you know it's a number one
omission all right what can I say I even
at Google right we pretty regularly run
into this the team presents here's what
they think the service is like and then
you actually go and you know you
actually go and do tours for example and
you look and the experience is totally
different we see it over and over again
I see it when I talk to companies that
are building products both on cloud and
not on cloud they really only
approximate what the user experiences
and you know why is this important well
let me give you a case study from from
Google's history ah defense-in-depth
very important concept in reliability
we're not going to talk about it today
but you just had it Illustrated so back
in 2004 Google launched this service
some of you may have heard of it it's
called Gmail it promised at the time a
gigabyte of storage whoo right back at a
time that was that was impressive I
think you got five megabytes on some of
the other popular services and people's
use of it was almost entirely
browser-based right there was there was
mobile adoption but it was not the
dominant way of accessing Gmail and so
the teams did what pretty much everybody
did which is well well let's look at
what's happening at the server right and
if we get the HTTP request and we send
the response and it took us you know 220
milliseconds on average to serve the
response and we had you know an error
rate of whatever 0.007 percent life is
good
it's that went on for a while we got
anecdotal reports that people saying oh
you know Gmail is slow and the
experiences is not really that great
especially if I'm you know not connected
to really fast you know two megahertz
Wi-Fi right etc etc and so eventually we
decided to launch a new gmail client
right it's it's JavaScript that actually
got downloaded when you started using
Gmail and we decided to instrument the
client and then we had the five stages
of grief
right started with starting with as it
always does denial right you know no no
this can't possibly be right right
there's no way it's like taking 20
seconds to load the inbox because when I
do it here at Google right on my
brand-new oh god at the time who knows
until a laptop running right running
Firefox it's nice and snappy right well
I don't need to spell the rest of it out
for you that is not the normal
experience and in fact the inbox load
times were very very very slow the mail
message load times were very slow in
some cases the page render times were
very slow you had to get through denial
so after a couple of rounds of like
making sure the metrics were right and
actually doing you know sort of tests
out in the field we convinced herself
okay actually no this is what the user
experiences wow that's pretty crappy and
we got eventually to bargaining which
basically became a whole new set of
changes both interestingly changes on
the server side right things like
delivering incremental
dates and delivering sort of real-time
feed and obviously on the client side
where you make rendering changes and you
change you know you change sort of how
the page is presented and so on you
actually might present it differently on
a different speed device so that you
don't consume too much of your time just
trying to literally draw the pixels on
the screen and I remember distinctly
this was 2006 ish
there was this inflection Gmail had been
growing beautifully right it had and up
into the right curve which I won that
was straight in the air and then we
launched the new client and then it's
curve did that right and it was this you
could correlate this change in the
adoption curve to us launching the new
client and the server updates that were
entirely due to having actually measured
the user experience in getting through
the five stages of grief and it was you
know it was a significant effort there
was a lot of debate at the time about
like is this important and shouldn't we
be adding a bunch of new features and
you know look at hotmail and look at
yahoo mail and etc but we spent the
effort to improve the client and to
improve the user experience for people
who didn't have the latest laptop and
didn't have the really fast Wi-Fi and so
on and it made this enormous difference
in actual adoption so for me that
cemented the lesson for forever right
measure the user experience even though
it's painful even though it's gonna take
you know a bunch of big engineering
projects because you will never build
your app the same way again
and you will get a much better user
adoption as a result of doing it much
more impactful than any feature that we
could have launched and yes it's hard
right so the engineering team will also
have to go through the five stages of
grief
in dealing with the fact that in
addition to writing all the features
they also need to write the things that
let you measure what the users are
seeing but persist metric number two
tail latency alright sounds incredibly
boring unless you're in reliability in
which case you know this is we live for
this stuff but what's let's run with
boring for right now right so quick
survey of the room hands up if you think
roughly you know how reliable your
service is ah see I gave way too much
away like the only people who are
raising their hands are the ones who
clearly do not know
because because they're in my team and
they already know what this drill is
right so yes we just talked about the
importance of actually measuring the
user experience the way the users
experience it but if you do that then
clearly you know how often the user gets
an error and therefore you know how
often your user considers your service
to be available if that describe you and
your perspective on your service right
now this will come as something of a
disappointment right so users typically
treat a sufficiently slow response as
the same thing as an error and they'll
do one of two things they'll hit refresh
if they're kind and think that otherwise
highly think of your app or they'll
switch to a different app and maybe
they'll come back to yours but certainly
they won't have a good experience and it
will be the same for them as if they had
gotten an error except the error at
least is sort of a polite prompt that
says you should hit refresh whereas no
answer is impolite and tells you to you
know waste your time and so I think of
availability as being the above formula
right availability is a hundred percent
- all of the errors that you return and
also - all of the slow responses you
give and you know if you picture this
for yourself right suppose you use a
nice snappy modern web based application
or mobile based application we offer a
few of them ourselves and on average you
know you sort of make a query and within
half a second the thing responds and
actually gives you the answer or does
the transition who I'd ever find that's
great right
so suppose one time in 30 whatever it
was that it was doing to process that
fails somewhere internally in your stack
and so eventually you know your timeouts
kick in and you assume you retry the
query for them as opposed to making them
hit refresh because you know that's
that's barbaric
but so you refresh after 10 seconds and
it retries ok so your availability
metrics there right we'll say that it's
99.9 something available because that's
how many errors you're serving your
users will say it's about 97% available
which is for a mobile app not terrible
but it's not great right most of the
mobile apps that I use they're probably
on the order of 99 percent available
I can definitely notice as a user the
difference between let's say 99.5 and 97
which is what I have here you'd have a
completely different view of what the
user experiences just by changing the
way that you consider availability and
so then the question of course becomes
well how much slower than median does
the thing have to be before the user
will consider it to be an error I don't
have a generic answer for you because it
depends a lot on your app right if
you're using an app like mail and it
takes a few extra seconds for a mail to
be received you don't even notice right
if it takes a few extra seconds for you
to hit Send before the mail is
registered as being sent you notice that
right and if you click on a mail and the
mail doesn't snap up instantly you're
going to retry it yourself in a couple
of seconds so maybe factor four but you
can probably see this and if you can't
you should figure it out right again
back to measuring the user experience
because you want to know at what point
your user thinks your app isn't working
correctly and if you don't know that
well your users do and you won't change
your app appropriately and then you'll
have less adoption and you know
eventually catastrophe so if you want a
rule of thumb write something to walk
away with 5 X 5 X is a pretty good rule
of thumb for many interactive
applications that I see people using and
it's not complicated at that point right
you can measure what your median latency
is just consider anything that's more
than five times as slow as your median
latency to be an error and you know
again five stages of grief right
followed by then you'll actually spend
some time and try to figure out really
is it five X or is it more like 8 X
right I encourage you not to be overly
optimistic because again you know
eventually the users will make their own
choice about your application you'd
really like to know what they're seeing
and how they're behaving and you'd like
to have the opportunity to tune your app
to deal with that but figure out what
latency you know starts to cause people
to retry or it starts to cause them to
switch off your app and do something
different for a while and come back and
tune yourself so that your tail latency
is below that and tune your metrics so
that once you hit that tail latency that
causes them to switch behavior you
consider in an error
and then you can decide how available
you want your app to be right but that
is actually measuring the the users
experience of availability and not you
know your servers experience of
availability and if you haven't measured
this sort of tail latency before like I
said just five stages of grief let it
happen right you'll get through it but
but don't stay in denial
so topic number three then is service
efficiency and this could mean a lot of
different things but it is the place
that I see the most applications get
tripped up on so I wanted to spend a bit
of time talking about it so let's talk
about capacity planning right it is as
boring and dry a topic as you could
possibly imagine for most developers
pretty much almost all developers I
think unless you're actually you know
charged with making sure the app works
in which case it is near and dear to
your heart right so capacity planning is
essentially a simple thing you take
demand right which you typically get
from historical behavior you extrapolate
it forward through time you add in
anything that we call inorganic but
basically if you're gonna change your
application to make the demand go up or
you know issue to queries instead of one
or write whatever you're gonna do that
changes your demand curve that you know
is gonna happen you add it in there you
divide that by how many servers it takes
to actually answer a query and there
again you know you can change the server
in blah blah blah but you know it's
probably been fairly constant over time
so you divide that and that tells you
how many servers you need or how many
instances you need or you know if you
happen to be stuck on a cloud product
that makes you buy stuff in advance to
get a good price how many you're gonna
have to purchase and and you're done
right easy peasy
well so you know unfortunately because
there is this extra bit which is that
you're all either developers in this
room or you manage developers for the
most part all of you are doing things to
that binary that's running on those
servers and you're doing things that
change the amount of time that is
required for processing a given query
right and so even if you are perfect at
extrapolating how many queries you're
going to be getting you're changing the
if you will the denominator and
sometimes you're not changing it by a
little bit right it was not uncommon for
us to see swings of 50 percent over the
course of a week
if you're not watching it because it's
easy to sort of add things to the inner
loop and it's easy to add a feature that
makes a call out to something else in
blah blah blah and even small changes
like configuration file changes can
sometimes dramatically change the amount
of compute capacity that's required to
process a query and we call that service
efficiency overall right how many CPU
cycles disk spindle seeks you know
Network bytes etc etc is required to
answer a query or to serve an
interesting action in your service and
like I said easy to change basically
invisible right unless you do
performance testing all the time which
we'll get to in a second and one of the
most frequent flyers in the post-mortem
that follows inevitably from this right
because of course what happens with
service efficiency is none of you
presumably run your services at the very
hairy edge of falling over all the time
right everyone builds redundancy into
how they do provision and either it's
redundancy to handle Peaks that happen
to happen right you're running a new
service and something interesting
happens in the world you can use your
own imagination this is what that might
be and you know demand spikes 30% or you
know you're running a photo application
and there's a concert and so within this
one area within there's one the
geographic region suddenly the number of
pictures people are taking you don't
even need that right just wait for New
Year's Eve and the number of pictures
that get taken on these hourly spikes
it's very odd right goes way up so you
have enough redundancy to handle spikes
and also to handle a certain amount of
failure right service efficiency changes
eat into that capacity reserve that
you've got but they do it invisibly
because normally you're provisioned to
have a bit of failure and if you don't
have a bit of failure happening at the
same time you have a spike everything
runs great right and so the post-mortem
usually reads something like we thought
we were provisioned n plus 2 for peak
but it turned out that over the past two
weeks our service efficiency had gone
down because reasons right which could
be like we introduced a new CPU type
that we were using or somebody check
something and like the list of reasons
is always different the result is always
the same right so it turned out we were
actually provisioned only n plus 5 and
then one of our sites had an outage and
then cascade failure right because once
you're out of capacity unless you've
done a very careful job of designing a
distributor
service to do very good loadshedding
right cascade failure all the way
through and then the only way to
recovered from that is basically shut
off all the traffic and then bleed a
little bit back in to get the cash it's
warm back up and eventually you can get
back to a stable operating model but it
takes hours and your users notice ask me
how I know this so the best practice
here is again sorry for creating more
work but this is really important
you got to measure how efficient your
service actually is at service inquiries
and I don't actually think that daily is
too frequently right the best practice
of course would be we'll build a system
that actually measures it for me and
spits out a report every night and then
I'll notice immediately it's much easier
to automate this sort of thing and have
a performance test and you don't have to
test every little edge case right you
just have to test the things that are
the big volume drivers for your service
but if you have it automated and you get
this report every night you'll notice
you'll also notice other interesting
things like hey you know our service
efficient still the same but our latency
has been creeping up a few milliseconds
every week right and so we've gone from
having a service that was nice and
snappy to a service that's kind of
kludgy even on a good device and really
bad on a bad device over the course of
three months without anything dramatic
happening right and that's obviously
something else that can bite you it
bites you mostly and that your user
adoption seems to know is over a bit
more than you would have hoped you know
if you're running hypothetically on a
cloud provider that just has flexible
use and so you can sort of use more
capacity you might not have a cascade
failure when your service efficiency
gets bad but will happen is your finance
person will come and find you a few
weeks later and they'll say huh you know
we got a bill from our cloud provider
and it's about 30% higher than we had
expected what's going on right and then
I would say typically two or three weeks
of thrashing goes on you accuse the
cloud provider of over billing you the
cloud provider you know does they run
Diagnostics that seems to be running
normally this is assuming you have a
cloud provider who lets you flex in and
out right if you have one where you're
running on fixed instances in your
service just goes down which has the
upside of no extra bill and you know
sort of prompt diagnosis so I guess you
know there's there's pros and cons to
each side personally I'd rather have the
finance team yelling at me than the
sales team but you know that's
right so to keep your cost under control
but more importantly to keep your
service table you've got to know what
your service efficiency is and the way
to know that because developers will
check stuff in that's what you pay them
for right the way to know that is to
actually benchmark it quite regularly so
that's actually it like if i trace most
of the big post-mortems where things
that were not sort of obvious we're
happening I could put them into one of
those three categories and so if you
measure those three metrics and go
through the work that it's going to take
to actually measure them accurately not
as an approximation I think you will
find that a your service runs better be
you have fewer outages and see you have
a lot more user adoption and you know
most of us kind of like those three
properties so that is it
[Music]
[Music]